when a film franchises great continuity
every element of it pulls together for
the final goal that delivers on all
fronts
however most movies missed the mark and
with so many different creators working
on one vision egos can get in the way
some films have got to the point that
you actually need to draw a time line on
a whiteboard in order to explain them
and it's getting beyond a bloody joke as
far as I'm concerned throughout this
video I'll be discussing the worst
offenders and their biggest mistakes
there will be heavy spoilers in this
list and you have been warned without
the way I'm definition and this is my
list of films with terrible timelines
x-men one of the biggest offenders is of
course the x-men franchise every time a
new director steps in they completely
ruin everything
whether it's how cerebro was created
what happened to Wolverine after
escaping alkali lake or how old angel
was like right how is he twenty years
old in the 80s and also a 20 year old in
the noise like like how are there two
mariah Taggarts two Emma Frost's and at
least three Jubilees and they all exist
in different decades but why does no one
care about these pointless things that I
lie in bed awake at night thinking about
behind a dress it began simply enough
with x-men and x2 then Brett Ratner came
on board and killed most of the
characters meaning that Hollywood had to
find a way to wreak on most of the
mistakes that he made by x-men origins
Wolverine Sabretooth was now somehow
Wolverines brother
Professor X just randomly showed up at
the end of the Wolverine with no real
explanation of how and why he was still
alive and mystique and Professor X are
now adopted siblings even though they
never mention it or make any reference
to it at all things got so bad that
x-men Days of Future past even decided
to wipe the slate clean and start things
again but
even that threw a spanner in the works
by having mystique disguises William
Stryker picking up Wolverines body at
the end Deadpool is just all over the
place and Logan has pretty much just
said look you idiot stop thinking about
it none of this happened that's actually
a quote from the film I think that's how
bad it's got the film creators are even
telling the audience to shut the [ __ ] up
like most things in the franchise
everything just gets brushed under the
rug and never mentioned again which
makes it frustrating for fans who are
sticklers for continuity terminator the
entire Terminator franchise focuses on
the question is the future set or do we
make it ourselves it's something that
the characters have struggled with and
even the films themselves some argue
that there is no future other than the
one that we make for our own while other
ones just blow everything up kill
everyone
let Christian Bale start a new trilogy
cancel it let him have a big shower a
member of staff who's just do nice job
probably getting paid nothing start
another trilogy and cancel it again the
first film is a perfect time loop Kyle
Reese travels back in time to create his
own son John Connor who then grows up to
send his father back the original film
clearly wasn't supposed to be part of a
franchise which is why they explicitly
state that no one other than Kyle and
the Terminator is coming back then t2
reckons this and centers around a now
teenage John Connor saving the world in
stopping Judgment Day but if the
apocalypse didn't happen and how could
John send back his father to be born
Terminator 3 then wreak on this again
and said actually may yet the apocalypse
is happening it's tomorrow and here's a
sexy fembot to chase you down for a bit
for the lads it's a teenage market we're
aiming at here so enjoy it
bye Terminator Genisys none of the prior
movies actually happened terminators
have been around since the 70s and
Skynet is now Facebook John Connor is
also a terminator or something
no he's now the villain that's returned
back in time to create new terminators
but Sarah Connor and Kyle Reese still
need to have sex to make him or
something
look it's just a mess I'm sorry but it's
just a mess Halloween
the most recent offender is Halloween
this series has had so many retcons that
it's best just binning all of your
blu-rays and picking up the first film
and nothing else
Halloween saw the rise of the murderous
mute my cole Meyers as he attacked the
town of Haddonfield Laurie Strode rose
to prominence and survived the attack
and by the second film she was revealed
to be the character's sister Halloween 3
season of the witch then took on a
totally new aesthetic and said that the
Halloween films were actually filmed in
that universe thus creating its own
timeline Halloween Ford then returned
with Michael Myers which continued with
the character for the rest of the films
Laurie was now dead in his continuity
but then she was resurrected and then
killed off again at a mental institution
or something anyway look scrapped that
she's back now those Maya's there you
just can't kill him anyway Michael Myers
was beheaded but then came back because
he put the costume on a security guard
or something
look it's ruined it's just it's just all
being ruined it's gotten to the point
now that the new Halloween which is also
called Halloween for some reason like
slow clap for Hollywood's creativity
there and that's just said forget
everything only the first film happened
they are brother and sister and that's
it I honestly really don't have much
faith that the series will even keep
this up and can completely imagine the
creative team pressing the big reset
button again when things get too messy
and also how is Michael Myers 61 in
still doing these things I'm 30 and I
can't even walk up the stairs without
losing my breath but anyway on to the
next one Highlander on-paper Highlander
should be pretty straightforward
the first film sent it around a group of
immortals battling one another for power
over the universe which it's its symbol
enough there can only be one yeah I get
it you get it it's easy the first film
is self-contained and doesn't need any
sequels but Hollywood just could keep
their grubby little hands of this cash
cow I learned it Tuesday about The
Immortals were in fact aliens from the
planet Zeist or something which was so
bad that the studio actually removed all
mention of it in further cuts of the
film for home video by Hyland at 3 it
turned out that there wasn't only one
and that the Immortals reappeared
throughout history and no one actually
had power over the universe
or anything look I don't know it's just
a mess just just don't introduce aliens
ever just just don't do it
never so what film franchise do you
think has the worst continuity is there
anything I missed
and what moment made you lose faith in a
film franchise comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and check out my other
film breakdowns which will be linked at
the end of this one this is a channel
for people who are mad about movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care
peace
[Music]
you